I want to welcome you into the house
come on Patrice Robinson is a member of
the Memphis city council so she was
shown the video of the beating of Tyree
Nichols at the hands of police before it
was released to the public and we share
with the world I was
overwhelmed
when we were so I saw the video
I saw it with my own eyes an injured
person sitting on the ground leaning up
against a car and no one giving them any
attention
seeing him bleed and in pain I it was
just inhumane
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions into the death of Tyree
Nichols including why police even pulled
him over in his car in the first place
even Robinson as a high-ranking city
official has still not gotten an answer
to that question they keep telling me it
was for a traffic offense but from the
video that I've seen I can't tell why
they stopped him but was even more
deplorable to me why would you be angry
when you just stopped somebody for a
traffic a violation
they never told him why we even pulled
them over or are we even trying to
handcuff you he had no idea and to me
that was the saddest part this is the
blueprint going forward the lawyer for
Nichols family has praised the Memphis
Police for the Swift punishment of the
officers
within three weeks all the officers were
fired criminal charges were pressed
against them and all were arrested we're
doing all that we know to do Robinson
thinks that sets a good example
separating bad police from the good ones
I know they are great people there I
have worked with great police officers
you have bad players everywhere but the
system may not be such that we can
readily identify who those bad players
are and that's something we've got to
get in place immediately because we
don't want this to happen again now I'm
going to have citizens who are afraid of
the police as well so what do you do
city leaders like Robinson are in the
middle of self-reflection on policing
and likely will be for a long time to
come Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Memphis